journée spéciale pour ces six élèves du
lycée louis-blériot de trappes ce
mercredi 26 mai ils ont pu discuter avec
une députée européenne dans le cadre
d'un programme erasmus débutant en 2018
la femme politique française irène
tôlerie a pu partager son expérience
lors d'une séance de questions réponses
pendant une heure j'ai trouvé super
intéressant il ya eu beaucoup d'échangés
entre les élèves et et la députée
européenne pour apprendre ce que plus en
profondeur ce qu'une personne dans un
poste de député européen puisse faire de
manière générale on peut on peut savoir
à peu près ce qu'ils font l'intégralité
de ce rendez-vous a été réalisée en
anglais pour pouvoir permettre à
plusieurs classes étrangères partenaires
de participer
l'événement s'est déroulé en simultané
dans des classes chypriote néerlandais
et slovaque
l'occasion également pour les trappistes
de travail et des langues étrangères
ça permet de travailler l'anglais oui
parce qu'on a une plateforme
virtuel où les élèves entre les visites
ont réalisé des activités et bien sûr
les échanges et en anglais ils ont
également appris quelques mots de langue
de nos partenaires des slovaques de
drake
ce type d'initiative n'est pas inédite
pour la structure des programmes
européens sont menées depuis une dizaine
d'années à trappes
on en voit régulièrement nos élèves en
stage et puis ce projet a permis à des
élèves de cp de terminale bac pro et 1re
bac pro de travailler en commun sur un
projet
en relation avec la clôture d'autres
animations sont programmées jusqu'à ce
vendredi dans la structure avec
notamment une visite virtuelle du
parlement européen
ce partenariat entre le lycée erasmus va
continuer à se développer se poursuivra
au minimum pendant encore sept ans